[Music]
this fall
six cities
prepare
for two
[Applause]
rebels with a cause
if you like it you should have put a
ring pop on and you know what i'm saying
you think genghis khan would stand for
this [ __ ]
phoenix
houston
charleston nashville new york
baltimore
the rebels with a cause comedy tour
tickets on sale now at
louderwithcrowder.com
tour
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
speedy
[Music]
um
that's a wonderful sip from uh the club
that is mug uh before anything else look
live with carter.com mug club uh go in
there check it out and if you're student
veteran active military you will get 30
off they are banning people left and
right on the roe v wade stuff so
we will get into the double standard
there because the left is actively and
hamas calling for violent revolution
violent insurrection across this country
the media may not be covering it you may
think it was mostly peaceful there were
acts of violence breaking out across
nearly every major city in this country
certainly the ones that i can think of
so uh but the standard doesn't apply to
you so we don't know what will happen
here because uh i don't advocate
violence unless someone's trying to burn
down your church or crisis pregnancy
center then fan the hammer
clear enough
um so gonna be talking about that all
across basically all across the the
country and of course showing you the
best of the best as it relates to the uh
the roe v wade protesters and they look
exactly whatever you had in your head
that's exactly how they look nailed it
uh before he when gerald a is here the
best man the better man he's doing well
and uh the fastest man on his feet and
he's with me on tour live
earthquaker.com
tour by the way houston is september
17th ahoy at the smart financial center
and then charleston west virginia
october 8th ahoy so we added some other
shows in nashville and phoenix is
expanding but those two are shows that
uh you know a lot of you asked for it so
uh go and buy tickets you doing well
dave i'm doing good
not the grammar doing good doing well
yes oh i'm feeling well i know that you
know better than that i'm fine i sat
next to a british man on the plane who
was drunk yesterday well you repeat
yourself yes
and you said he threw up many times yeah
how was that for did i just smell like
uh this smell like uh it felt like a man
who was ordering drinks i've never heard
of her yeah and it's like i have a
buckle soda and you're like i'm sorry
are we on a british cruise line oh no
here comes the bangers and mash
i hope you don't mind it's little bumpy
i'm going to throw up on everything yes
i'm going to throw up food that nobody
likes going in i'm glad you worked this
hard for a first class
not to be out done there was a scot in
the back i've got
that's haggis whole plane is weird this
is a weird weird european throw-up group
[Laughter]
speaking of one you'll throw up let's go
right into it uh our favorite uh
look i'm being no i'm being sarcastic
yeah
michael rappaport uh he took to
tick-tock which is always a good sign to
attack uh and i don't know why this
isn't racist but and by the way let me
just tell you some people asking like
well where do you line up because some
people think that
i think that justice clarence thomas is
a pump
and we'll put together his five greatest
hits uh probably tomorrow or sometime
this week because he is the target right
now
because he was willing to uh go out on a
shield on this one he was very clear in
the
reasoning of his decision which people
do not like which i agree with by the
way not that i don't like him i agree
with his reasoning yeah in his opinion i
really recommend that you read his
opinion it was uh fantastic uh but
michael rapaport took the tick tock to
attack justice thomas in this idiotic
and you decide if it's racist rant
you overturned roe versus wade
and the leader of the pack clarence
thomas you handsy can't say a pack for
nothing sexual harassing [ __ ]
you you creep
you creep if you had gotten what you
want from anita hill with your overtures
and your sexual advancements never
happened and you had somehow some way
impregnated her
right being married and all that right
mr judge mr supreme court judge if you
had impregnated an anita hill what would
you have done with that baby you [ __ ]
worm you you would have aborted it
logical fallacy there we go the abortion
and you'd have paid the hush money
because you're a creep
sucker you
a bunch of fake phony [ __ ] out
there
what would you have done with that baby
clarence
pupicare clarence your freak your freaky
little horny old
dirty breath and i know your breath
smells like
old coffee newspaper and stale band-aids
you creepy cook you now
just imagine if it were a white
conservative saying that about a black
uh a black lady well
can you edit and go back and record on
tick-tock
yeah i don't know if he has that button
is it because coffee breath and
band-aids was just the and that's in
brian
he's pulling a brian de palma he's done
like 46 takes before he uploaded that
wow that's the best he could come up
with exactly it sounds like that's the
snake eyes of rappaport's clarence
thomas insults
poopypants judge you poopypants judge
what would you have done with anita hill
huh you would have aborted it that's
what they rather than addressing what it
is that clarence tom judge clarence
thomas said it's make up a scenario
first off you guys can go back and look
at anita hill the reason that people
didn't believe it's like brett kavanaugh
people still act as it was real it
wasn't they tried to say that he was
going to a cd porno store which couldn't
have possibly could not have possibly
happened because it didn't exist when he
lived in that locale his great crime
when people consider sexual harassment
is something that makes me like him more
where he had a like a little eyelash or
something on his dad cocaine so like hey
who put that pubic hair in a dark
cocaine i'm just getting ah
good for him
that was it
do we have the inside video on that
where he's like
[Laughter]
just pull a deaf comedy jam just a beat
comes down
[Laughter]
musical intermissions
seriously that was the big thing for
people who don't know if you're you're
younger you're watching that was that
was you know where joe biden used the
n-word in front of him and he just
decided to everything was racially
motivated with clarence thomas because
like you saw with samuel jackson calling
him uncle clarence these are actually
racially motivated oh yeah insults fine
if you want to do it
let's just apply your own standards and
i hope that you choke on them but i love
that clarence thomas made a joke about
someone short and curly being on his
diet coke can
i just makes me want to party with
thomas it may have been one maybe i
don't know you have no idea what those
interns do yeah unbelievable i do it all
the time
right joe
so speaking of black women uh and by the
way i don't want to say black women
because it's an insult to black women it
is and just to be clear when we say
beetlejuice
i mean the beetlejuice from howard stern
but like you said she kind of looks like
she had sex with michael keaton's
beetlejuice yes so it's two beetlejuice
i think she looks like michael keaton
beale juice no no she looks more like
with both of them we'll go we'll talk
about it more
it's a combo so lori lightfoot america's
mayor as nobody refers to her
also berated justice clarence thomas
with some harsh words
now we know what happened with the
supreme court yesterday and if you write
clarence commons concurrence he said
thank you
clarence thomas
[Applause]
wow
yeah that was just what she writes on
her dating app who's she opening for
pantera
right
yeah f clarence thomas now
skid row without sebastian buck yeah
he's welcome twisted sister
in the most corrupt city in the world
how is what dirt does she have on people
that she's the mayor of chicago
oh which is she stares at you for more
than three minutes and you're like all
right
yeah she's stealing people's souls she
probably has a lot of dirt left over
from all the shallow graves of her
political opponents that's unbelievable
that lady is just so weird but anyway i
thought it was i thought we weren't
supposed to say f anybody in politics i
thought that was a bad thing to say
unless it's donald trump or
now apparently a black man on the
supreme court yeah i just i thought that
was weird look and this is the promise
that they've they've by their own
standards have called for violence and
my ques look here's a question to you
what do you think happens here in this
country after roe v wade comment below
do you i think that this could maybe
slightly hurt republicans in the
midterms because the left is on an
all-out assault and trying to create a
false narrative and using false polling
data that being said i talked about this
on last friday's show that's how we
ended the show as you can turn this into
a win by simply educating people which
we will try and do today i guess there's
a new supreme court ruling that's
happening right now you guys can let me
know we'll talk about it later uh yeah
actually actually came out
again same kind of split as the roe v
wade decision where a coach who was
praying at the 50-yard line
actually you know guess what they
recognized a right in the constitution
and said yes there is a first amendment
he has a right to go and pray at the
50-yard line it's not coerced he can go
do it that was it people were mad that
someone was praying at the 50-yard line
well yes apparently went all the way to
the supreme court because i think he was
fired for that or at least uh there was
some kind of penalty i mean i understand
if he's you know doing uh doing the
muslim call to prayer 50 yards up what a
plane yeah that's true i'd be concerned
yeah well in the middle of the game
right well it hurts yes yeah they had
that when i was playing at the 50-yard
line whoever wanted to go and pray at
the 50-yard line after the game could
nobody was forced to nobody was
ostracized for not doing it you got
about half of the people from both teams
that would go there and pray and you
leave like what's the big deal
separation of church and state
yes separation of church and 50-yard
line by someone personally praying i
guess yeah
it even came to the school board's
attention from an opposing coach an
opposing coach in 2015
heard about the prayers and said he
thought it was pretty cool
the opposing coach thought it was cool
and an opposing coach wow yeah so i love
it so it upset everyone yes
no he thought it was pretty cool that he
could do that no i know apparently by
saying that he got the guy in trouble
well we'll get to the kinds of people
that uh it uh really pissed off because
we have pictures of all the feminists ah
at the uh at the pro abortion rallies
yeah picture them in your head
you don't need to watch the segment
you'll already know no you got it it's
exactly what you think it is yeah if you
guys want to pray to the spaghetti
monster in the sky you can do that at
the one yard line yeah totally fine you
can have your own thing well i mean some
of these ladies ladies the the feminists
the uh the abortion i don't know if
they're the anti-roe v wade overturning
rallies
they could be deities they're huge they
in certain cultures that's a sign of
wealth yep being that big yeah
here it's a sign of wealth you'll
survive the winner i'm poor uh
it is a sign of poor as well yeah i mean
general gelatinous well you're not that
poor i mean you're able to feed yourself
that much yeah we're very little yeah
have you seen
have you read what's in the bags
how many people are going to bed hungry
every night that's what they're like
people are going to bed hungry every
night well not the people at these
protests apparently they're going to bed
engorged yeah what are they eating
veruca salts chewing gum food so it's an
everlasting doritos yes
it's an everlasting dorito taco yes
your cholesterol it keeps going up up up
and up ah
you're turning into a taco
there's no knowing where your ldl is
going our triglycerides are growing
it's a totally different take all right
we're just saying so here let's start
this off with why has there been so much
violence this weekend and by the way all
references will be avail will be
available at light of credit.com and
we're going to create a hit list of all
the crimes being committed in violent
actions being committed uh here at these
uh pro-abortion rallies anti-roe v wade
protests and uh i'd like to hear from
you if you went to one locally uh below
let me know what it is that you saw
maybe you can actually
they have to be crazy to serve publicly
well she this is like her 50th time
calling for violence right so remember
when donald trump said you have to make
your voices heard peacefully and then he
said fight like hell right which by the
way you can buy these shirts at the
merch store um maxine waters called on
people to commit really sedition
by saying defy the supreme court so this
sets the stage for all of the violence
that ensues
you see this turn out here
you ain't seen nothing yet
women are going to control their bodies
no matter how they try and stop us the
hell with the supreme court we will defy
them women will be how about you control
your body off a cliff
black women
are afraid they got another thought
coming black women will be out in droves
we will be out by the thousands we will
be out by the millions we are going to
make sure we fight by the right to
control everybody thank you hello
everybody
yeah hello he's just waving like the
queen hello everybody throws candy
let's go let's go out and kill kids
everybody well yeah let's do that so
again just applying their own rules we
are going to have a montage probably
tomorrow maybe wednesday of just every
single politician who said fight or
literally fight like hell
i think that you have the right to say
that but again in the context here these
are people who are calling their
supporters who by the way they know are
more irrational statistically
uh to take to the streets here's aoc
uh who amazingly formed several
sentences together to encourage uh
violence
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
good thing is it doesn't affect her
because she has a doorman apartment in a
nice area of virginia and a tesla yeah
so
unsurprisingly a megaphone yeah
online
probably
uh i don't know if you're surprised by
this dave you weren't here on on friday
but things got pretty ugly and then over
the course of the weekend people did
start exercising their first amendment
rights as those at the tea party did
right or as those largely as it deals
with the uh election um results that
they believed uh you know included some
discrepancies which of course makes him
a terrorist
no wait sorry uh
immediately violent
that's a flamethrower against the cop oh
wow burned his face
[Applause]
peaceful
oh
just wish that fence was barbed wire
what's wrong sir you like killing babies
you love killing babies i can love
killing babies you love killing babies
you love that don't you you love that
he really thought that was a good
counter argument yeah do you like
killing babies count counterpoint i'm a
rapist oh boy shouldn't say that on
camera
follow me
i'll follow you
okay i feel really bad for these cops
man i mean a couple of years ago these
guys were in the streets trying to
defend cities from blm like can you
imagine being thousands of officers yeah
thousands of officers casualties like
not knowing if you were coming home that
night now they're back out on the
streets because people are protesting
this largely in places that don't really
change any rules doesn't change anything
we'll get to that by the way they're
protesting largely in states where they
can still kill babies by the way long
after most of these european countries
by the way europe hey
shut up how about that shut up europe
underground i can't believe this in
america no really where do you stop
abortion in france
where do you stop abortion in germany
then compare it to colorado and
california dummy
we want your opinion we'll give it to
you yes exactly when we want your
opinion we'll throw a bunch of your
important
[ __ ] in the harbor
i believe they perform it in france just
by putting the legs in the stirrups and
blowing cigarette smokes exactly yes
exactly croissant said it's 20 effective
they just
well they make use of the day old
baguettes the scraps are the old one
don't put it two ways then
is it very hard
so
terrible it's scientific no it's true
you can start a soft spot with bread
let's go to los angeles let's start off
with los angeles everyone's favorite
place of peaceful protest
the land of los angeles riots rodney
king and reginald denny uh here's a man
who was arrested for attempted murder
you just saw it he used a flame thrower
on the police
there you go you can see it from the
tall shot did you guys see that yep
aimed it right at the cops face
behind an umbrella
oh and by the way hey uh control room go
on my twitter and find there was a clip
that i posted where there was a black
couple who the police were going by
going for ant for protesters and they're
sitting there with their hand standing
with their hands up and the cops usher
them to safety and go after the white
guy causing trouble if they're racist
they're really really bad at it that's
on my twitter there we can pull it up in
a little bit here also protesters in los
angeles deciding to block off the 110
freeway
hey there david well everything was
orderly until it wasn't i want to put
this into context we have been following
several protests in downtown l.a today
uh i would say upwards of 3 000 or so
protesters in various groups have made
their way over to city hall but a
portion of the protesters i would
estimate about several hundred have just
entered the 110 freeway in the last five
minutes this was not exactly if you want
to lose sympathy for a protest and lay
really fast make
next thing is a bunch of land whale
feminists just decide to lay down over
the 405's like you are now a gelatinous
speed bump yeah
i'm sorry i'm not taking any chances
with that i saw how it went when the blm
writes again going back to that like how
many people's cars were vandalized kids
screaming in the back seats crying not
knowing if they were about to get shot
helmets like being used to bash in
windows i'm not staying there i mean of
course not i'm going i'm sorry if you
got in the way by the way hey hey
dummies abortion is allowed in
california still all the way up to
viability and by the way with tremendous
exceptions it's pretty much on demand so
it affects you zero okay let's just be
clear about that and yeah you should see
the tool kit that i have in my car now
yeah
to ensure that it's non-lethal of course
i have pepper spray
grenade pepper spray grenade i have a
push bumper yeah and have uh what i
refer to as bago snakes
it's a bag of snakes i feel like it's
the perfect no it's just a bag of
rattlesnakes yeah i don't have the
rattlesnakes in my car but i have them
you know and i have them in a snake
snake atarium whatever we call it and i
just think that it'd be perfect to go
down there and just like an old david
and goliath sling throw a bag of snakes
out at these protesters because there's
no evidence people it would take a while
for them to process like what is that is
that is that a diamondback rattling
rattlesnake and they there you go you
now have the right-of-way that's true
yeah i think i could just drop like a
bees nest off of the bridge like as
they're coming something like that maybe
or bago spiders i know you would never
go to the store and get that one no but
they can't they can squash the spiders
snakes would force them let's do a
tarantula something really big my point
is this you no longer need to be a
sitting duck when you're seeing these
acts of violence being committed go out
protest make your voices heard
peacefully in your places of worship at
your crisis pregnancy centers hug your
wives kiss your children
or kiss your wives hug your children it
depends if you're italian whatever you
do
and we have that yeah
do we have that video that's lapd so
watch this because the narrative and
we'll talk about this tomorrow that
ending abortion is racist watch this
this is something that a lot of people
miss you see a black couple older black
couple yeah
completely
unharmed watch this
so they're going after these protesters
look black couple right there
now as they start following these other
guys causing crap look
they run away and a cop makes sure that
they get away safely
hey hey stop see that look at me listen
hey what happened hannah i thought if
you had your hands up to the lapd they
were going to shoot you yes they go all
right come on get out of here they're
going we don't know what's going on it's
a bunch it's a bunch of self
well it's a bunch of racist white people
don't say self-loathing it's a bunch of
racist white people saying that they're
speaking for black people but right
there the only black people in that shot
that i can see
two
older black people hands up police help
them out so they can beat the ass of the
white uh the white disrupter good
yeah it's not the 90s where they clearly
would have just shot all the black
people right yeah that's exactly what
we've been talking about you're right
here please go to safety service so i'm
apologizing for all that apologies
i mean she's in a pink track suit no
one's a no one's threatened by well no
it's they're not doing anything wrong so
clearly that's what happened but that's
the point is when they tried to say mike
brown's hands were up no wait hold on
mike brown had taken the cop's gun and
was beating him in the head with it they
were up what like this right yeah
swinging back they're sitting there like
hey and you know what you're making it
hard for police officers to protect
people in these neighborhoods people
actually live in these neighborhoods you
show up you leave the refuse and guess
what they have to deal with it cops
helped them good on you police officers
and i'm not supporting the police all
across but this was a bad weekend for
them i was amazed
at uh their restraint let's go to
arizona here's some protesters in
phoenix who uh sieged the capitol
building
[Applause]
thank god no one let them in for a tour
yeah no kidding
good thing that cone was there
great job cone
[Applause]
that's officer phone oh that's such a
woman way to try and
try and break the glass with the
cardboard sign yeah i want to do it
this guy's just going to get a snack
what's going on here oh this is weird
get it going get the cone good morning
ladies and by the way there were
lawmakers inside they were working uh
there was a you know the 2022 session
there uh at least four people were
arrested and of course they all look
like huge creeps that looks like
it looks like the guy from uh house
party just like he had a final
destination failure with his hair dryer
yeah house party seven when they're all
just doing math they're right
he's forgotten how to rap and by the way
hey dummies arizona allows for abortion
up to 15 weeks still
which is more than most of these
countries in europe yeah they're
protesting for you know and consolidate
know four months
with the rest of the country for almost
four months long time almost four months
i didn't i didn't know i was pregnant
would your roommate replace your birth
control with baby aspirin hey is this
considered a violent uh insurrection no
no no no is this is this an attack on
democracy no not at all okay so people
were still there trying to finish the
legislative session
even though they've literally said we
are going to either dissolve the courts
or just flat-out ignore the courts did
you see the pentagon someone can guys
bring that the pentagon just said
they're going to ignore the court ruling
yeah hey by the way don't join the
military now
hey navy
screw you hey pentagon you're not our
friends
the pentagon has decided they're going
to ignore the courts and you and then
we're blamed for not trusting our
institutions well hold on a second
what about the fact that people say okay
you know this is kind of how the supreme
court is supposed to operate
this is a process we understand it isn't
the pentagon supposed to be subject to
the law of the land that's an in so
which institution are you vilifying us
for not trusting
the court doing exactly what it's
supposed to do yeah or the pentagon
flagrantly disregarding the look because
that's an institution and all of
america's military and intelligence uh
agencies have a great track record don't
they fbi cia don't trust any of them
anymore
i can't watch u.s marshals again
for many reasons right mainly because of
the movie yes
i thought it was going to be like
fugitive too it was not it was not it's
no i agree i saw it and i was like well
that's a one-way that is a terrible
spin-off by the way i love the take on
people saying that this is an overreach
by the court they're they're taking
power that they shouldn't have and i'm
like literally the court looked at a
document and said yeah that we got no
ruling over that we have no power to
rule over this so you guys take care of
it
that was all they did they gave power
back to people well as of right now
they're trying to figure out what can be
put in place or is in place to what's
medically safe for the mother is that
correct yeah a lot of states right now
are grappling with that yeah states are
states are able to set their own rights
or yeah how they're gonna do it i just i
just think it's just the dumbest take in
other words the most radical
pro-abortion law that exists in
california or colorado they can keep it
yeah texas can do what they want
mississippi can do what they want oh but
now i have to drive
are we back to the id argument are can
you never be expected to be an adult
all right let's go to washington dc
uh ant of course took to the street to
uh declare very publicly which almost
like you should it's like the wet
bandits don't say on camera that you're
about to commit a felony right
repeatedly they're chanting all the
great ones have their calling cards
chanting that they're going to burn the
city down not build this city
they burn the city down
[Music]
[Applause]
we don't get it
they don't we don't get it
[Music]
okay uh hey dummies abortion is legal
all stages of pregnancy in dc just to be
clear all the way up until and including
nine months all right yeah it affects
you zero do you remember all these like
uh my body of my choice if we don't get
it we'll burn this mother down kind of
things and politicians coming out when
the the vaccines we've talked about this
before like do you remember seeing those
protests yes about their choice we get
to do we get to handle our own bodies
right
medical decision with our own doctor
well the good news is they don't need to
worry about abortions because they can't
get pregnant after they took those
vaccines
allegedly allegedly i'm kidding i all do
remember lizard but that's because a lot
of them tried to use it like a squirt
gun
doesn't work here's secretary of defense
lloyd j austin iii the department is the
sorry the department is examining this
decision closely and evaluating our
policies to ensure we continue to
provide seamless access to reproductive
health care as permitted by federal law
uh there was an actual statement though
i think by the pentagon saying that they
would perform use those they would still
perform the abortion services for their
own uh their own members
maybe one of them owns a one-hour
martinizing yep maybe
if we don't get it burn down the city
never mind they built this
the jail bandits let's go to the
pregnancy clinics remember we told you
hey be really careful uh if you're a
church or pregnant now many of them have
been vandalized this has happened again
we'll have the hit list all the
references available at
lightworkcredit.com
uh here's longmont
longmont colorado uh life choices
pregnancy center and let's be clear
about something too when we're talking
about this the places they are burning
down i don't know how much familiarity
you have with this uh uh
dave but my you know i've had a lot of
friends and family who've worked at
crisis pregnancy centers non-planned
parenthood uh crisis pregnancy centers
which is also hilarious that planned
parenthood claims only three percent of
their services are abortions but not
like we're gonna have to shut down
really why because she went down by
three percent that'd be like rite aid
having to shut down because i can no
longer sell junior mints well it's not
that big of a profit margin well rite
aid went down because they could sell
everything yes
a rite aid went down because it was rite
aid yeah exactly it's like 7-eleven you
walk in you're like is this is this a
pauly shore early 90s horrible comedy
why don't you guys get some new flooring
what can i can i eat whatever's on this
roller i mean you can you can trade take
your chances why would you go ahead we
just stopped putting expiration dates on
anything because
i mean it's better for us that way
that's all roulette yeah it's a roulette
so uh a lot of these crisis pregnancy
centers just to be clear they actually
offer ultrasounds they actually offer
medical services they actually offer so
i know one that was here in texas where
i had a family member work with they
actually offered
adoption services uh nannying services
daycare services and resources for
single mothers afterward they offer more
than all right get in the stirrups chop
chop so life choices pregnancy center in
longmont colorado was uh not only tagged
with graffiti but set on fire
picture that said you know if we can
have our abortions we're coming after
you those words now spray painted on the
front of the life choices pregnancy
resource center in longmont so they do
like ultrasounds and pregnancy tests and
all that they look too pretty above and
beyond that if
the woman does decide to parent then
they give her
you know clothing and formula and
just a lot of support becky young was
both a former client and employee when
she heard the building was set on fire
and vandalized she was shocked it was
like that is such a weird
place to
target i guess longmont police and fire
responding to life choices just after
three saturday morning finding the spray
paint and the fire which is now being
investigated as arson
investigated as arson they wrote that
this is arson yeah
spray paint all over the building
they're like well i don't know air i
guess it's as good as mine yes
let's bring in the arsenal list again on
this one
my my hands are tired let's not jump to
conclusions it could have just been
those taggers with their graffiti which
is also stupid by the way uh and then
just on a separate instance uh next to
where it says we are burning down this
building uh someone else burned down the
building lightning strike thanks columbo
natural christmas spell the if with a t
right
hey i don't know if you know this by the
way colorado and we did a hidden camera
uh investigation there not investigation
we just went to an abortion clinic in
colorado and there was a lady there
having an abortion at 32 weeks she
stopped because of us
left i know so you get really mad when
we save a life we get really mad when
you take one so i know you're seething
but yeah that lady who was going to get
an abortion at 32 weeks she stopped
because of us we convinced her to not do
it the misogynist prick right here
convinced a woman to keep her baby come
at me bro in colorado abortion is legal
up until birth okay
it affects you zero
why attack the building in colorado
because they don't like crisis pregnancy
centers that actually provide education
do you know what you'll never see if you
go to if you go to planned parenthood or
you go to an abortion clinic in colorado
and aboard a baby at 32 weeks
28 weeks you'll never see what the baby
looks like because you don't have to and
if they go to a crisis pregnancy center
and this is why it's important to
prosecute and to go after the doctors
who knowingly are merchants of death
because most of the mothers have no idea
they've been told that it's as simple as
you know an appendectomy
having a goiter removed which lori
lightfoot has had many well and a lot of
times all they'll do is show you an
ultrasound and when when women see their
child in their womb like you connect you
have to face the fact of what you're
about to do and it's helpful when
pregnant persons see a child in their
body hole
birthing women birthing person pregnant
men on the cover
of kelvin klein yes
that's a magazine on a billboard i mean
yeah
big big change from marky mark
yeah i mean but imagine imagine having
that like view i can understand somebody
and i disagree with it wholeheartedly i
can understand somebody holding a
different view on roe than i hold right
i disagree 100
but can you imagine being so mad about
that that your your outlet of choice is
to go after something that actually
takes care of women who choose
to go and maybe pursue other options
like that is your deal is to go after
somebody who provides services to the
community that you say you're trying to
serve by making sure abortions it's my
choice well what if they choose to go to
the crisis pregnancy center yeah burn it
down i mean do they show up in like the
old school van tackle them into a
fountain and throw them in and take them
there i don't think that's what happened
they show up in the april o'neil news
van yeah
they're taking out competition that's
evil that it's just absolute pure do we
have the stinger of deal i would take
tomorrow do we have that i remember we
haven't done that in a while but let me
grab it okay so
let me know when you do because i i i
was just thinking about that because uh
i would gladly take this deal um let's
go to virginia here before i do that
uh lynchburg virginia
i knew this media company oh do you all
right here's a deal that i would take
tomorrow okay well we're talking about
this
ah it's been a while since we've used
that okay look
abortions for the left so aoc lori
lightfoot this is to you to maxine
waters
okay i will campaign for you
i mean this i will tell all of my
viewers to vote for you legitimately
i will spend money on social media
advertising for you if
what you support is
abortions legal all the way up until
including birth
with the exclusion of trans people
meaning only for biological women if you
are willing to say abortion
it's the woman's choice
and you make sure that it does not
include transgender individuals trans
men trans women
i will support that deal tomorrow and i
will campaign for you if you are willing
to put your stamp on it and no longer
say pregnant persons if not it just
shows how silly all of this is that's
the deal that i would take tomorrow
[Music]
you can't even stop tripping over
themselves
her head's exploding right now very fair
to you i would say it's actually tilted
in their favor a little bit it's very
tilted she's like in there
[Music]
you get over swayed back you just have
to say that
men can't get pregnant yes
because if you can't define
woman
or pregnant or womb
how can you define a life not a bi i'm
not a marine biologist right yeah
they're not i'm not hooper
hey don't get me this working-class
trans [ __ ]
so
i have a a helpful place to burn down
yes
we're gonna need a bigger we're gonna
need a bigger forcep
forcep four steps i don't know the point
is this if you can't define man woman
pregnant womb
you're not even going to trying to find
baby or a life let's move on down the
trail in lynchburg lynchburg virginia
vandals shattered multiple windows at
the blue ridge pregnancy center they
also left what i would argue is a
threatening uh
threatening uh graffiti over there uh
right outside of dc too yeah
unfortunately it says if abortion ain't
safe
you ain't safe
hey again dummies governor juncken's law
maybe not as generous as northum
governor blackface but still allows
abortion up to
in between 15 and 20 weeks
ridiculous isn't uh 20 weeks 20 weeks
you're showing about five months yeah
you can still kill your babies sorry
person whatever oh no it can't say
personals with human beings you can't
say woman you can't say man and then
with babies you can't say baby or person
you see how they change the rules what's
a life what's a baby what makes a human
being a human being what makes a woman
they can't define and by they because i
know you're watching aoc you can't
define
any of it
your college degree means nothing if you
have to say birthing persons
sorry i can't say
gosh
your birth person just had a gender
blank yes
that's a very good deal overread oh by
the way i know the best mid uh person to
help you with your yeah
birth
with your bad
you know what i don't care language is
regressing
we're just not able to communicate
here's some other pregnancy centers that
were vandalized again we're gonna have a
hitless ladder with credit.com so you
can see all of them dearborn heights
michigan which is odd because they make
most of their money off of clitoral
circumcision you would think so well
they weren't protesting that paso robles
california
um
and uh look i have to address this it's
a joke guys of course not you guys i'm
just talking about the two muslims that
are like hey hey it's true hey we do it
but they like it come on
we we we still have the kids
don't enjoy the process at all yeah go
protest uh the conservative policies
there in dearborn yeah go do that see
how that
goes okay we got a gross point instead
no we have to go to dearborn i think
i'll stay home that's what we thought
yeah ladies go yell at him but don't
forget keep your mask on now i have to
address this and just to be clear
this guy is one of those guys you say
his name three times in a mirror and he
shows up
um
i never with the vox adpocalypse sorry
about that youtube the borderline sorry
about that they created what's known in
the industry as the crowder rule um
carlos mazza was the guy who
went to these leftist outlets to create
a hit list on us and our argument was
never really with carlos mazza it was
with nbc
vox right but they fired him because he
was annoying enough and a problem to
them uh that uh now he's kind of gone
solo and he's shown his true color so if
he can't get people cancelled and have
their livelihoods removed he's totally
fine having people's lives removed so
carlos mazza
tweeted this out okay when we're talking
about violence this is the most
egregious example i think fascists
literally do not care how hard you vote
they're not trying to win elections
violence is the only language they
understand and it's time to it's time
we start speaking it
the whole point of democratic governance
is to create an alternative to violence
when the government is no longer
democratic you're supposed to go back to
plan
a here's the thing
this is going back to democratic do you
understand that the court said the
states can now decide through their
elected officials what the court said is
it's not our job to decide
if texas wants to democratically decide
through the representatives that they
want a heartbeat though they can and if
you in colorado want to decide abortion
all the way up until and including birth
you can't this has nothing to do with
viability or life and many of people
like us don't think it goes far enough
in that respect but at least it gives
the power back to states yeah this is
kicking it back to democratic
institutions and this man is calling for
violence by the way also insinuated that
people need to burn down the supreme
court just to be clear
also retweeted a tweet showing brett
kavanaugh's address just to be clear
when we had the vox apocalypse with this
little piss ant
i can i feel like he's earned it right
now for some personal yeah
it's gender neutral yeah lispy pissant
gay wonk is his twitter handle nobody
should go and and report him and nobody
should go at all and let him know that
he shouldn't be uh tweeting calls to
violence even though he you know he
blocked me a long time ago yeah gay wonk
gay wonk yeah don't don't address his
gayness though no don't actually say
that word towards him oh cause he
becomes offended very quickly right
it's like going a fat burger and they
say can't say burger well what am i
supposed to say fat fat yeah like what
did you just say give me a double fat so
keep in mind youtube had a problem by
the way with us selling the socialism is
for fake shirt off the site yeah if we
continue to sell it off the set so we
can still remove you for things that you
do off platform really
particularly if it's public like social
media platforms or things that are
publicly available uh
can apply the same standard youtube just
asking you to apply the same standard
hey twitter how about applying any
standard here yeah
it would be nice and by the way i hate
this this is like a five-year-old temper
tantrum that we're seeing from the left
right now if you are on the left and you
want roe v wade to be the law of the
land there's a path forward it's called
a constitutional amendment and then when
it gets to the supreme court you know
what they're gonna do they're gonna
unfurl the paper and go oh it's there i
guess we have to rule for it right now
they're saying it's not there we can't
do anything about it right that's how
this is supposed to work all of these
places where people are violent and
protesting they don't understand that
they have no clue what will probably
happen in their states is they'll become
even more radical
they'll probably extend their abortion
laws yeah and then in places like texas
they uh they'll they'll reduce it well
and i love companies these like billion
dollars billion billion dollar companies
out there that are saying hey we'll pay
you four thousand dollars to travel out
of state and get an abortion yes that's
a hell of a lot cheaper than three
months of paid maternity leave and the
disruption of having a kid don't think
that they're on your side right now
they're looking at it going huh we can
make more money and keep you at your
desk and by the way these people who
think they're harriet tubman like the
underground railroad you're just taking
a bunch of just taking a bunch of women
who couldn't be bothered to use a rubber
across states so they don't have to pay
for an abortion look this whole idea
that you're we're anti-choice no i'm not
i've talked about this so many times is
there any accountability is there any
responsibility i'm pro-five choices
abstinence contraception motherhood
adoption and by the way most of these
other crisis pregnancy centers help with
those other options there's four options
just don't support the fifth
in murder isn't that reasonable
isn't that a reasonable approach
come on and then saying look even if you
don't agree with me you live in a god
forsaken state filled with demons and
ghouls
and wendy goes guess what you can do
whatever you want in colorado and by the
way i hope that everybody leaves states
like texas and oklahoma and idaho and
they go back they crawl back into the
rubble from once they came hey by the
way before we move on because we're not
calling anybody to violence but i am
calling you to defend
your house your home your businesses if
it comes down to that uh you can watch
us monday through thursday 10 a.m
eastern on rumble or on mug club uh lot
of crowder.com
mug club uh that's where you can watch
us because notifications don't
necessarily work though hit the
notification bell if you can about 10 of
you will find that notifications work
and the rest of you won't
all right
anything else no okay
now let's get to the childish portion
here
[Laughter]
you know that's coming yeah
because um
this is you know full display has been
everywhere roe versus wade these
protests
and if you follow me on twitter at s
crowder you'll see that i've responded
to some of them in real time um too much
to the chagrin of um
several planets
it's time now to at least bring you the
best of the best and it's time to uh
introduce a new segment we call
unadulterated ad hominem
all right
so here are some pictures of the
abortion protests that were just taken
and by the way when we're on mud club we
have some exclusive info from gingersnap
he was there in dc yeah yeah and someone
tried to take his camera oh it was his
first time i'm like man you should be
thankful you weren't punched in the face
and kicked in the nuts like i was
jumping jacks for life baby so uh dave
you you were uh you weren't around any
of these protests uh i went uh and
looked at the one in detroit yeah a
little but there wasn't really much i
was gonna film it but there it didn't
really take off until the night time
yeah well also probably because it's
largely black people in detroit and
they're honestly with this one they're
not the ones often going out there does
seem to be with a lot of black women who
are more traditional black women they
don't want to go out and celebrate
abortion even if they are pro-abortion i
don't think most people that have had
one want to celebrate it and i think
it's a very personal thing i mean i
don't
well these pictures might just see how
this all plays out i i don't really
well
but no it's not it was not big downtown
okay so we got some for you hold on here
hold on to your butts uh picture what
you think these women look like
that's exactly what they look like let's
go to the first example i don't know i'm
going by these blind here there you go
this says this one says i am a six out
of ten and uh keep abortion safe now
first off when i saw this i thought i
was careful because i thought she was
saying that she was six so did i but
then i realized the tattoo and then i
realized that she was there at the
abortion rally and it turns out that she
is of age and then it's just that's just
offensive because i think that uh first
off a two would be very generous it was
she royalty yes
is she on a hunger strike i have no idea
i don't think so geez
i'm a six out of ten ooh
i don't know about you being a little
generous to yourself their love oh my
why
why does that help
i don't even know why it's relevant
that's just someone who really wanted to
let everyone know that she was a six
yeah yeah but just you take your shirt
off and it's not like anybody sees
anything right ah it's a boy it's like
oh hey well what this lady claims she's
a six out of ten wait do you mean behind
the greyhound yes there's a little gay
fellow with a man yes i ever want to
make love to a skeleton
skin
that's like oh no no thank you no excuse
me little boy do you need help holding
your sign up
who stole your shirts little boy
get them a sandwich i'm a six out of ten
keep what does that even mean here's a
protein shake what does that even mean
her parents had ten kids is that what
that meant
six out of ten children that makes sense
yeah is that it well if i were if i were
her parents i would have them running
around with numbers
i mean if i would number them all one
one through ten and then it would be
hard to find a place to fit a six oh you
know what i do i would label them all
like one through uh eleven but then i
would just have like number seven
missing so the kids would always be
looking for their entire life if you
raised ten kids it would be that you'd
have every right to be pro boys yes
exactly and by the way we need to be
clear with the math
two threes does not equal a six so if
this girl is a twin
you're being misleading
it's true
and if by the way i would assume that if
she is a twin that she's the one who
didn't get the placenta the other one
get out of here
get out of here i'm a sex
it says tell it to a judge that one got
double paddies
all right here's another example i
believe this one was here in uh dallas
there are more of us well dear god i
hope not what is that uh that's gene
simmons in uh
is that a henna tattoo or a cheese is
that real
who's next to her
there are more of us no they're not
another aren't this is the problem the
media will highlight these people as
though they're normal
there are not more of you there are not
more of you who believe in abortion all
the way up until birth and including
birth period who also can't define where
life begins there are more of us and
thank
god there aren't doesn't that looks like
gene simmons in a corset yes it does i
can't really see her too well i don't
see too good bob
oh no don't zoom in you got a hair oh
hairy armpits that's how you know she's
fun to talk i thought it was an armpit
tattoo oh it's a fright wig yes okay
okay there we go i wasn't sure there are
more of us just look at the level of
delusion working or pleasing a man on a
sunday yeah well i don't think that i
think more so she would be upsetting a
man yes right stop
go
get away no please do something nope but
i can just stop i'll pay you
that's not how this works
oh i think buddy i think this is one
that i really uh if i'm not mistaken
this next one let's see this next lady
right here oh it says if my uterus what
she says of my uterus shot bullets it
would have more weights sweetheart that
thing could fit a howitzer yeah it's uh
it's in
capone's tommy guns yeah what's that
just she's going to pop out the moab
well that's not a woman is it uh
and then from the back
i love you guys
and then from the back where about it's
like but from the back she just she's
white she looks like slob job it says
this is also racism what this is also
racism it's not a mask by the way it's a
permanent napkin
i always have a bib if my uterus shot
bullets oh my gosh i mean that thing i
mean that thing itself could be a
biological weapon i don't imagine you're
going to planned parenthood and the
doctor's like you think you're what
i'm a four out of ten there's no
possible way there's no way you're pre
yeah yeah you're pregnant i hope uh you
don't miss carrie right yeah no your
body is clearly a perfect incubator for
the miracle that is life yes
huge
nope nope that wasn't the problem
if you just want to put your situation
on the table with your
your your font yes
[Laughter]
at least dress up i mean come on you're
dressed up really look at her come on
she put some effort into that look at
that oh that's true it doesn't match no
bra bandana
that draw string which she clearly had
to replace because it's not the right
color no the
let's go with green today yeah yeah
is it slimming
let me put on some vertical stripes
that's i mean something something with a
taper
i'm just kidding it won't help they were
like ah this is why we made the uh
grimace purple yes
that's terrible although she in real
life is the hamburglar
none are safe that's true she's also
giving birth to some fry kids
you can fit the entire burger king kid
club in that uterus
and believe me what comes out is
definitely the one in the chair yes
if my uterus shat bullets this is the
level of logic no one said that guns
have rights they said that human beings
have the right to protect themselves
just like a
okay let's take this let's take a kid in
a wheel someone in a wheelchair if
someone in a wheelchair doesn't have the
ability to protect themselves do you
have the right to harm them no of course
not just because they're defenseless
doesn't mean that you have the right to
harm them it's the same thing for that
baby in that cavern from the descent you
call a uterus
yeah
i agree
i might have cried out loud did she have
she didn't have a fanny pack
there's no way they all have fanny packs
did she have a fanny pack her fanny ate
it
it was lunch
it was way bigger
it was a once upon a fanny pack
it's the biggest one you ever saw and uh
this is the grand finale because this
hits and by the way some of you are
saying oh this is ad hominem yes
absolutely the grand finale here we go
another protester
this one hits all the marks look look
let me just show you exactly why okay
first off you got massively overweight
there you go okay then you got the horn
rim glasses right okay then you got the
uh the the ironic fanny pack right and
it's michael moore yes then you have the
ironically expensive phone for the
oppressed
and then you have ill-placed tattoos
indicating fiscal irresponsibility
and then of course the final accessory
is a desperate unattractive man behind
you to convince you that the rest of the
world is wrong and that you are in fact
beautiful just the way you are
this is the feminist pro-abortion
starter pack
[Applause]
available at gender neutral spencers
everywhere with that stance so that you
don't break a leg yes can you imagine
just the guy at the tattoo parlor
how much would that be it's eleven
thousand dollars yeah
why it's your whole upper thigh your
back is 12 square foot not to mention
the device that we have to use to keep
that skin taut it's like what they do
with your eyelids for lasik only with
your legs just like they crank it
you didn't see me change the needle 117
i read out of green so i'm just gonna
have to finish this with is that
whatever is that satan on her i don't
know how many
i don't know how many rolls of paper to
hell i went through but there are four
garbage bags right over there
what is that tattoo
what is the tattoo uh is it satan or is
it a lion is it like a knocker from a
like an old like door looks kind of
satanic i don't know no it looks like it
could be wow you're right about a door
knocker is it majora's mask
uh it looks like a yeah like a lion mask
maybe either way
either way
bourbon legend says that uh if you see
the full tattoo
three minutes later you throw up yes you
know
either which way right when you say
you've passed out from smell
[Laughter]
even looking at that if she were here i
wouldn't ask her to lift her
jeans up so i could see the recipe no
i'm just i'll just oh yes yeah nobody's
ever said that's lovely what is that
what's the top of it yeah and go back to
that guy behind her can we show that guy
behind her the full look at that that
guy's just like that guy's like look i'm
at the uh
i'm at the fanny pack i'm gonna take
what i can get mode
oh yeah he definitely is he just got
rejected by a six
look at him what's he filming
he's filming her she's filming the back
of her mushroom cut oh boy yeah that is
a nice haircut okay honey yeah she did
that with a flowbee that morning
sucking my will to live oh lord
oh gosh it's peter griffin undercover
you know what though i feel like we
should be the wingman of that guy and
get him some money we should help him
yeah we should help him
well no
by what no but kicking his butt into
shape
oh no i thought he was saying by kicking
him into her dms a two can at least get
a five yes yes if you had a negative
no
he doesn't have to wake up to the smell
of mustard gas
[Laughter]
he does not enjoy the smell of napalm in
the morning no
and by the way do you think this is too
much you can comment below because uh
when it comes to these ghouls uh i make
no apologies this has been unadulterated
at hominem
all right
and really quickly uh i want to also
address one of these things uh
i almost got confused in creating a
counter argument have you have you heard
and you can comment below and by the way
hit the like button uh that does help
with the algorithm
have you heard
the argument
that
overturning roe v wade is about white
supremacy and of course you have because
they argue that everything is white
supremacy but specifically that
overturning roe v wade is racist um
and they're calling the decision of
course the dobbs case racist so um
it it it defies reason to the point
where you can get turned around yeah in
trying to
you know they make their off their lot
their illogical offer
and here's my counter offer then wait
hold on a second wait what was the offer
it doesn't make any sense so uh let me
just set it up iona presley along with
elon omar corey bush wrote a letter to
biden demanding that he do everything in
his power to ensure black women can
receive
abortions
because that's the sign of people who
are not racist
i know that's why i say this is tough to
follow go with me here okay go with me
and i'm going to circle back around and
it'll all make sense it's not going to
make sense when i set it up with the
arguments directly from the left all
references available at
loudouncredit.com here is a clip that
was circulating yesterday as though it
was a real
checkmate
only these people they weren't even
playing checkers they were they were
playing uno uh
banning abort here's a claim that
they're making with this video that
banning abortion is white supremacy so
that more white babies are born and
they'll maintain the birth rates this is
this is real this was the top five trend
on twitter yesterday and right now white
people are really frightened if you
don't understand the destruction of
planned parenthood
offices
and you don't understand the wall that
we're going to build on the southern
border of the united states you haven't
read the book the birth dearth by ben
wattenberg ben watenberg was a brilliant
jewish man who was a member of the
american enterprise institute and he
wrote a book the first paragraph of
which says
the main problem confronting the united
states today is there aren't enough
white babies being born in this country
he was an advisor to presidents of the
united states he wrote the book in 1987.
he says there are if we don't change
this and change it rapidly white people
will lose their numerical majority in
this country and this will no longer be
a white man's land now i'm not
misresenting misrepresenting this i'm
telling you exactly almost exactly what
he says he says there are three things
we can do to solve this number one we
could pay women to have babies as they
have been doing in western european
nations for years then he says and these
are his words not mine unfortunately we
would have to pay women of all colors to
have babies so we don't want to do that
he says the second thing we could do is
increase the number of legal immigrants
that are allowed into this country every
year then once again he says
unfortunately the vast majority of those
wanting to come to this country today
are people of color so we don't want to
do that the third thing he says and
white men women had better pay attention
to this
sixty percent of the fetuses that are
aborted every year are white if we could
keep that sixty percent alive that would
solve our birth dearth
does that sound like racism to you
and if it doesn't i want to know why it
doesn't okay let me explain to you
exactly why it doesn't let me hit you
with the truth here and let me go with
this this is important notice he just
said
if we could maintain the 60 percent of
white women stop those abortions here's
the issue always across the board going
back to the founder margaret sanger and
in practice today statistically
undeniable
they never want to stop black abortions
in other words you can say it's white
supremacy
because he wanted to stop white
abortions but he didn't want to stop
black abortions
you guys meaning the left you still
fulfill half of that and that you
encourage
more black abortions you're not stopping
white abortions but you understand that
black women
commit they have abortions committed
against them let's use that term they
have they perform abortions they have
abortions performed on them at four
times the rate of white women let me
give you a stat that'll shock you
about 40 of black babies are aborted
that means that a baby in a womb of a
black baby in a womb has almost as much
of a chance of being born
as they do of being aborted it's almost
it's pretty close to the 50 50 shot 60
40 shot
those aren't odds that you would like to
take if your life depended on it by the
way insert municipalities where they
have aggressive pro-abortion campaigns
like new york more black babies are
actually aborted then even born yeah new
york taking accounts for about 10
or so of all the abortions as well yes
and by the way more more black babies
will be born if abortions are restricted
or they're banned just to be clear yeah
and proportionally they would probably
grow as a part of the population at a
faster rate than white people because
often black women have more babies so in
other words we're the ones being
consistent saying how about no abortions
across the board the left is saying more
abortions for black people and they're
trying to make it sound like it's white
supremacy because some guy said if we
could only ban abortion for white people
well he didn't want to ban abortion for
black people you know who else didn't
the founder of planned parenthood
margaret sanger i know you're trying to
create some distance no no no we're
going to bring her right back in here
let's read some quotes we should hire
three or four colored ministers
preferably with social service
backgrounds and with engaging
personalities we don't want the word to
get out that we want to exterminate the
negro population
and the minister and the minister is the
man who can straighten out that idea if
it ever occurs
to any of their more rebellious members
margaret sanger was a eugenicist
let's be clear you can read quotes you
can take quotes out of context you can
also try and take some examples of
racists who have policies on abortion
but you have to go just like i say with
islam to muhammad the founder of the
feast planned parenthood margaret sanger
she was a racist she didn't by the way
didn't just want to set up abortion
clinics
in poor areas
not poor white areas to the same degree
as black areas period
so there's been one group that has been
consistent by the way and it's the same
group who were furious just as they are
today when the slaves were freed
across the board
i have no idea how you can make the
argument that this is a white
supremacist racist thing first of all
clarence thomas the first person that
they're pissed off at right now as a
black man i know he has a white wife and
that's you know really taboo i guess you
guys are living in the 80s still but
there's no way you can look at this and
say that the black community is not over
represented in abortions we gave you
that stat too i think they're two or
three times more likely per 1000 women
to have had abortions in each one of
those categories it's two or three times
more likely that a woman
a black woman has had an abortion they
account for a much smaller they get
abortions at four times the rate they
get at four times the rate but just per
thousand women like okay you look at it
versus white and hispanic and
non-hispanic
they they absolutely are over
represented in this how can you not look
at this and say what the hell is going
on i don't want white babies being
aborted i don't wanna play anybody how
about that i just don't wanna tell a
community of women right now if they're
four times more likely what are we
telling the community to make that
happen what are we saying to them that
says hey there are no consequences go do
this right margaret sanger this is her
dream scenario right that everything
that's being put on these women in this
community and trust me i'm saying it's
being put on them because they're being
lied to
daily just like to say go have sex as
much as you want
no consequences whatsoever we will keep
this from being a problem for you and by
the way it's just it's the abortion
equivalent of lyndon johnson's dream
scenario with the model studies program
it's great we can keep keep black people
in poverty we can keep them in certain
areas of the city so they won't bother
other white people and we'll keep them
we'll keep them on the government don't
we'll call it public housing we'll call
them social projects we'll call this uh
uh we'll call this reproductive rights
for black women so you look at their
policies hey black women stay reliant
upon the government be a baby mama
because we're actually going to
discourage getting married and having a
man in the house and get abortions
that's what they have said you need
abortions you need
public housing by the way you don't need
an id to isn't that racist and at a
certain point now there are enough black
people going
i don't think it's racist i have to need
id
i don't want to live in public housing
anymore um kind of like muhammad ali
when they asked why did you move out of
uh out of i think it was chicago he said
at a certain point said to get away from
black people that's what he said yeah he
said to get away from the black
neighborhoods at that point because
there wasn't any help in it by the way
muhammad ali no one talks about the fact
that he endorsed ronald reagan and
campaign for orrin hash we'll do a
segment on that maybe when we go on
break here this july
by the way share the show if you are
watching right now and i wanted to um
close here with a thought
because there is a lot of
uh rhetoric going on about fight like
hell you hear that a lot you know you
hear fight the term they tried to make
that uh out to be a term of violence one
used figuratively you can buy the fight
like hell shirt at crowdershop.com
but we hear the german a lot and i
shared it recently with a
good friend of mine who um someone had
cancer
knows someone has cancer and said you
know this person's a fighter and we use
that term a lot
and i think it's important that we
define what it is right we hear the term
ah she's a fighter he's a fighter well
first off let's separate it right the
term what does it mean
and how can you be a fighter how do i at
least how i define it i'd love to hear
if you agree with this or disagree but
let's separate a professional fighter
for a second right that's a term
we mean this is an analogy when we're
saying this person's a fighter they're a
fighter in general in life
but still there is some
there is some applicability there
so fighters professional fighters they
win and they lose
muhammad ali lost
would anyone ever say he was he wasn't a
fighter
of course george champier lost was he
not a fighter
of course we wouldn't say of course they
were
so when people say oh he's a fighter
right that's the best chance we've got
he's a fighter oh she's a fighter oh
fight like this person fights like hell
what does it mean
it doesn't mean that you win all of them
like i said with professional fighters
what does it mean to be a fighter it
really boils down to something pretty
simple
it starts with one simple word and it's
one that's often vilified
no
someone who's willing to consistently
say
no
that's the start
of every fight they often say oh
republicans are the party of no
conservatives of the party have no
you're right the supreme court just said
no
we we don't agree we don't have that
authority
americans could go along and get along
and say sure you know what the easiest
thing is okay abortion is the law of the
land think about robbie this is a long
standing fight
and the people who fought all the way up
to the supreme court
for a long time just it started with
them saying
no
it's always easier to get along
if you go along
like maybe your friends want you to do
drugs you don't want to do drugs maybe
they want you to mug that lady play the
knockout game whatever it is
now maybe you're sick maybe you're in
the hospital and you're tired been going
through some treatments that are tough
and i get it at some points there be
easier to give into death
you say no
that's what makes a fighter maybe it's
easier to just avoid saying something
and this is where we all are right even
if we i'm taking some
severe examples to paint a scenario but
for all of us maybe it's just easier to
avoid saying anything when your friends
talk politics religion values or maybe
they say that all trump voters and all
conservatives and all republicans insert
whatever group here are christians or
fascists and nazis and a lot of the time
which is a lot and particularly with
with often nice women
good women who want to keep the peace
your friends will say all these things
and instead of just well maybe
you say
no
that's what it is
a fight starts with no
any physical fight that you've ever seen
between two guys started with one saying
yes and one saying no effectively one
saying i'm going to take your lunch and
the guy's saying no you're not taking my
lunch money one saying i'm going to talk
about your mother this way the guy going
nope
no is a line
get in the van
no
that's a fighter get in the alleyway no
get on your knees
no
every fight in life starts with you
finally saying no why because no is a
start of rebellion
no is a start of stating publicly
emphatically putting your stamp on where
you stand no i won't do that no i won't
shut up no
that's wrong every single one of those
examples is the start of a fight
that's where it begins and you know what
all of you all of you right now at this
point in this country when actual acts
of violence are being committed against
you not just words you have to accept
that
you have to accept that someone says
something
you say no
and that's the start of the fight and
unfortunately now they're willing to get
physical
you say no and let the cards fall where
they may you'll win some
you'll lose some some people win more
than they lose doesn't matter there are
fighters with losing records they're
still fighters
you've got to decide if that's what you
are
but if you start with no and you stick
with it and you keep saying no and you
keep sticking with it win lose or draw
guess what you're a fighter
that's the term we always say he's a
fighter there you go that's it it's no
for long enough
no i don't care what your record is
if it's oh and 25 you showed up
and enough no's enough fights enough
rebelling once others have given up and
you're still standing
eventually
you're going to earn yourself some wins
but either way you have earned the right
to call yourself
a fighter keep saying no fight like hell
never stop
it's that simple all right we're gonna
go and uh we have some exclusive info
here uh uh regarding uh regarding
gingersnap in washington dc and uh dave
is going to be july 15th through 16th
columbus ohio at the funny bone yes and
29th and 30th omaha nebraska at that
funny bone
let's go piss off youtube
[Music]